on this friday night
critical compensation for indigenous
canadians
two class action lawsuits over unsafe
water
settled when the water touches her her
feet
she's filled with pain the agreement
worth billions
the worsening fears a fourth wave is on
the way
plus mounting questions about needing a
third vaccine dose
the rise in taliban takeovers and
targets
the race to help off-guard interpreters
in danger
and batter up the boys of summer are
back
we're happy that we're able to come home
after striking out for nearly
two years major league baseball returns
to canada
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with an historic
settlement on something that most
canadians take for granted but
that so many indigenous canadians in
this country don't have access to
clean drinking water the federal
government is committing nearly eight
billion dollars to settle
two class action lawsuits from first
nations over unsafe drinking water
there are communities that have been
without safe water for decades and the
toll
is immense growing up
avoiding tap water was the way of life
don't put your toothbrush in it
don't rinse your mouth make sure you
have enough bottled water to get through
the long weekend
and people would get sick from the water
i got sick
and my family got sick michigan
first nation has been with this
water crisis for close to three decades
closing in on 27 years
we often wonder in our community
why it has taken so long
to provide something
for our first nation i i could sit here
and
try and give you all the excuses in the
world but there is no credible excuse
for countries
such as canada to take this long
indigenous services minister mark miller
laid out the agreement in principle with
leaders from three of the plaintiff
communities
nishkaniga first nation curve lake first
nation and tataskuya cree nation
the settlement must still be approved by
the courts but
is said to modernize canada's first
nations drinking water legislation
and offer 1.5 billion dollars in
compensation
to those deprived of clean drinking
water about 142
000 people from 258 first nations
are expected to receive compensation and
that number
could rise the proposed settlement
includes a commitment of at least
six billion dollars over the next decade
to provide reliable access to that safe
water
including creating a first nations
advisory committee
supporting first nations in developing
their own water initiatives
and making ottawa responsible for
private water systems
such as wells right now there are at
least 51
long-term drinking water advisories in
32
first nations and to the pandemic
canada's top health officials are
warning we could see a fourth wave of
covid19
by the end of the summer with just five
weeks until the labor day long weekend
the highly contagious delta variant is
already fueling it
since july 18th canada's r number is
trending
above 1 and rising that means one
infected person will spread it to more
than one
other signaling early signs of epidemic
growth
66 percent of the population is now
fully vaccinated but
canada's top doctor wants that number to
be above 80 percent
across all age groups before we begin to
gather indoors again this fall
while canada still has a ways to go to
hit that target
alberta is pushing ahead with its plan
to end its pandemic response
and as heather urex west reports there
are fears the policy shift
could put people in other provinces at
risk
last spring tanis mcconnell lived
through a parent's worst nightmare
her seven-year-old son hunter spent
several days
in intensive care it was terrifying he's
hooked up to so many things
and i think the second day he was there
they came in and started
oxygen so we knew things were
were really bad hunter was diagnosed
with multi-system inflammatory syndrome
or ms c a condition that occurs in kids
several weeks after they've contracted
covet 19.
mcconnell worries alberta's decision to
end its pandemic response plan
a move that would mean less testing and
contact tracing
and no longer require covet positive
cases to quarantine
will put more children at risk
in calgary and edmonton friday several
hundred people gathered to protest
canada's chief public health officer
expressed concern as well
if the policy in alberta is
is not to mandate that then i
would ask at any individual who is
diagnosed
with covet 19 or you think you may have
it
please isolate alberta is far from
finished with covid19
modeling out of the university of
victoria shows that cases are currently
rising much
faster than they did in the previous
waves at this
pace cases could reach the height of the
spring wave
by september the projections also show
hospital and icu numbers rising
towards the end of summer unless there's
something that's going to mediate that
it's going to be a large outbreak call
it a fourth wave
through the unvaccinated population and
because of you know
the incomplete efficacy of the vaccine
through some of the vaccinated
population
creating a potentially dangerous
situation
just as kids still ineligible for
vaccine head back to school
this fall heather urex west global news
calgary
the fourth wave concerns are being
fueled by the rapid spread
of the delta variant new modeling
released by the public health agency of
canada
shows the variant is the most
transmissible to
date and has an increased risk for
hospitalization
internal documents out of the u.s are
also sounding the alarm about the delta
variant
they show it can cause more severe
illness than earlier variants
and spreads as easily as chickenpox
the data has many wondering whether
there is a need to start thinking about
booster shots
today israel announced it would offer a
third dose of the pfizer biontech
vaccine to people over 60
the first country to do so president
isaac herzog was the first to roll up
his sleeves
former prime minister benjamin netanyahu
also received a third dose
so far there is little science to back
up the need for a booster yet
but as michael couture reports canada's
health leaders say they're watching the
evolving data
closely why are there 6.3 million
you know canadians who are eligible to
get a vaccine haven't even received
their first dose
what are you waiting for before offering
booster shots the deputy chief public
health officer of canada
wants to reach residents of this country
who are still reticent about vaccines
if they needed proof of protection
public health officials provided
these stats less than one percent of
fully vaccinated people
have been hospitalized because of covet
19
and just half a percent even got the
disease
after getting full protection i think
people should
be very heartened by the fact
that the breakthrough infections are
very few israel has announced it will
start offering
a third shot or booster of the pfizer
biontech vaccine to people over the age
of 60
based on some data suggesting a decline
in immunity
over time canada's top doctor says
officials
are looking at the evolving data we're
getting operationally ready
whether it is looking at supplies
whether it's looking at the
implementation pfizer suggests its third
dose is effective against the more
deadly delta variant beyond the
protection offered
by the standard two doses but some
virologists
caution the company's claim could lack
the full context
we're seeing a lot of data or a lot of
updates in regards to science that that
is being released to the public through
press release
rather than through uh through actual
scientific literature
before some countries get a third poorer
nations are still struggling to get
first
doses the world health organization
believes
70 percent vaccine coverage globally
will slow transmission
and we're not there yet the highest
priority has got to be helping all
countries get to
at least 10 percent of their population
vaccinated 20 percent 40 percent
deputy prime minister christopher phelan
said canada has a moral responsibility
to help get vaccines to the rest of the
world
but she added the government will follow
the advice of our medical officials
when it comes to a potential booster
shot
michael couture global news ottawa
today finance minister christa freeland
announced the extension of covet 19
emergency benefits until late october
but with a looming fourth wave there is
concern
non-essential workers may not be able to
cope with another wave of job losses
and gaviola reports calgary resident
nicole menzies has
turned to serb and ei three times once
during each wave of shutdowns
i've always been very much in control of
my finances
and my living situation and to all of a
sudden
be so unsure of that particularly
in a pandemic when people are too
terrified to go outside like it was just
so scary
the mother of two says her finances were
stretched before kovid and the aid was a
lifeline for her family
i'm really grateful it saved me my
mental health
it saved my home and it put food in our
cupboards
with covid case counts climbing in
alberta there's growing concern about
the impact of a potential fourth wave
which economists say could hit just as
current supports from the federal
government
come to an end in early fall the
governments may decide to keep
a couple of the other kinds of
restrictions in place with respect to
capacity limits in retail settings for
example so those sort of things could
carry on a little further than
perhaps otherwise expected when asked
about extending emergency aid for
workers the federal employment
minister's office said in a statement to
global news
we've had canadians back since the
beginning of the pandemic and we will
continue to be there for them
labor experts say even if a fourth wave
doesn't result in further shutdowns and
job losses it is likely to hamper
earnings
you can't force people to go out and so
if there is a general fear
of catching covet 19 of going to a
hospital
there's certainly likely to be some
psychological impact and therefore some
financial impact for those front line
businesses
analysts say government officials need
to move from a reactive policy approach
to a strategy for managing covet over
the longer term from a passport system
to a vaccine program that involves
booster shots policy in general has been
created around the expectation that
eventually
the pandemic will end and will return to
a state of normal
but we may not actually see that ann
gaviola global news toronto
japan is expanding its state of
emergency after reporting a record spike
in infections
the order now includes four more areas
in addition to tokyo
emergency measures will remain in place
until the end of
august after the olympics and well into
the paralympics
tokyo reported record increases in covid
19 cases for three days in a row
before logging more than 3 thousand
today
officials say the surge is being fueled
by the delta variant
canada added another medal to the
collection in tokyo
it is the country's 11th of the game so
far the gold captured by the women's
eight rowing crew
the country's second rowing medal in as
many days
swimmer penny alexia didn't meddle
during her 100 meter freestyle event but
she still delivered a canadian
record-setting performance
crystal gamansing has more they call it
the cox win toss
it's a winner's ritual to dunk the team
member who steered the crew to victory
a tradition the canadian women have been
waiting
a generation to take part in when we
crossed the finish line and it really
happened our dream came true
and right now we just get to
celebrate it and be really proud of
ourselves and really embrace this once
in a lifetime moment
the last time canada won gold for
women's eight crew rowing event was in
1992
madison mainly wasn't even born yet felt
like
uh yeah fairy tale ending almost to this
crazy past especially two years i guess
it's a feeling the women's soccer team
can likely relate to
they'll get a shot at a third
consecutive olympic medal
after defeating brazil the game came
down to a
nail-biting round of penalty kicks
canada now turns its attention to the
semi-final match
monday against the u.s swimmer
penniolexiac hit the water with her
usual
intensity but it didn't result in a
medal
she did however swim the 100 meter
freestyle
faster than she ever has and broke a
canadian record
penny is inspiring you know young women
to to see that that the things that they
feel passionate about which could be
sports or it could be arts it could be
you know whatever it is um i mean that
as a woman and as a mother
i mean again that's that's inspiring to
me there will be more
inspiring moments as the games move into
the second week of competition
athletics gets underway and that means
we'll see
favorites such as sprinter andre de
grasse
crystal gamansen global news london
canada's 11 medals puts us in 11th place
in the overall standings china is at the
top with the most
gold 19 so far and the u.s has the most
medals overall
with 41. it's the intense burden of
trying to be the world's best
coming up the mental health disorders
top athletes are at risk of developing
plus houston we have a problem how the
international space station got
knocked off course
when olympic gymnast simone biles walked
away from the final this week
she put mental health at center stage
now a study the first of its kind in
canada has found our
elite athletes are at greater risk of a
mental health disorder
than the general public and as global
news health reporter jamie morocco found
out
asking for help isn't as simple as it
sounds
preparing for the tokyo olympics in 2019
canadian softball player larissa
franklin
says she could feel something was wrong
i just had this mindset
every single day of like i didn't do
enough anxious about her performance the
now 28 year old says she was facing
burnout
a study out of the university of toronto
found 41
percent of our elite athletes meet
criteria for one or more mental
disorders
including depression anxiety and eating
disorders
i was quite surprised by because that
number is quite high
but maybe i shouldn't have been because
that's also quite reflective of research
from
elite athletes in other countries uk
researchers found 48 percent of athletes
surveyed experienced
similar symptoms and in australia the
number is even higher
at 50 percent there's this really
important dedication to the sport that
sort of creates the potential for stress
canadian athletes cited stress and
training load as main factors impacting
their mental health
decorated swimmer mark tewksbury
highlighted post olympic depression in
the 90s
and says there is support now athletes
have access to
to mental health professionals 24 7
on a telephone line they have access to
appointments whenever they need them all
the teams have a
psychologist traveling with them and
team canada has a chief
medical officer and a chief psychologist
that's over there in tokyo right now
but for franklin seeking help meant
risking her dreams
i felt like if it got back to the coach
then
then he was going to assume that i
wasn't ready to step up to the plate and
perform
on canada's softball team franklin says
there are monthly meetings with the
psychologist
a proactive approach experts say and a
start to changing the mental health
stigma
that still exists in the world of sports
jamie morocco global news toronto
ahead a comic killed by the taliban
stokes fears that canada has failed
afghans who helped our troops
the first group of afghans who worked
for american troops and face retaliation
from the taliban
has arrived in the u.s overnight about
200 landed in washington and were bused
to a military base in virginia
for medical screening while the u.s
program has begun its evacuation flights
the canadian program announced last week
is still only taking applications
as mike armstrong explains the murder
this week of an afghan comedian
is a brutal example of what interpreters
and other afghans who worked with
canadian troops
could face if they're not rescued and a
warning some of the images in this story
may be disturbing
if you had searched for his name online
a week ago
you would have found laughter
he was known as hasheswan a comedian in
kandahar who posted videos on social
media
if you search for his name now the video
that comes up first
is of his recent arrest by taliban
gunman
just before he was killed
[Music]
was an afghan interpreter who worked
with canadian troops he now lives in
vancouver
i got a bit a little bit emotional so
sorry
nori says hasheswan's killing at the
hands of the taliban shows their
brutality
and how afghanistan is growing more and
more dangerous
even for a comedian
he's a very funny guy his only aim
in life was just to make people people
laugh that's it fasciswan was shot
several times the taliban has taken
responsibility a spokesperson claims the
comedian worked with police and should
have been taken in front of a taliban
court
that didn't happen
there are reports in recent weeks of
hundreds of similar revenge
killings the taliban taking over parts
of the country and
going after people who worked with the
afghan government or
nato troops we reached one of the
interpreters who worked with canadian
troops who's in
hiding he's applied to move to canada
with his family we're protecting his
identity
he says the killing of the comedian is
what awaits anyone who worked with
canadian troops
if they don't get out of afghanistan and
the taliban
takes over they're doing the same thing
like they used to be
they're just killing people now there
has been criticism of ottawa's plan to
rescue
afghans that it started late and was
then slow to ramp up
many of them are in danger the federal
government friday admitted complications
but says it's doing its due diligence
vetting applicants
and recognizes the urgency
mike armstrong global news
it's been nearly two years too long next
toronto welcomes the blue jays home
talk about an out of this world oops the
international space station was briefly
knocked out of its position in orbit on
thursday
after a new russian science lab
accidentally fired off its thrusters
the lab which docked just hours before
caused the station to lose control for
nearly an hour
russian officials say a software glitch
was to blame
the station is now back into position
well after nearly two years away due to
the pandemic baseball has returned to
toronto
the blue jays are back home at rogers
center tonight for their game against
kansas city
and thousands of fans there will get to
see their long-awaited return
eric sorensen joins us from there
tonight and eric this
isn't just any other sports comeback
me too in this pandemic era no major
league baseball team has waited longer
to play home games
at home 670 days since september 2019
the itinerant toronto blue jays are
finally in toronto
there is anticipation and excitement
that has been absent from the cavernous
rogers center for almost two years we
are waiting for
more than 161 games i think so
this is the night pandemic restrictions
forced the team to play home games in
buffalo just across the border and in
dunedin florida
now the team has spruced up the stadium
and made it ready for the team
and its fans to return for games in
person
in canada we're making this a big deal
we're happy that we're able to come home
there will be covert protocols in place
just fifteen thousand fans allowed in
about a quarter of capacity
the roof will be open for all games even
on rain days there will be some open
circulation
fans will have to wear masks except when
eating and most will be seated next to
other fans
i think that's that little bit of normal
that everyone's been looking for to be
able to sit by your neighbor and
and celebrate the blue jays and
celebrate your team even with fifteen
thousand fans the risk from the highly
transmissible delta variant is believed
to be small
for now anyway i think that right now is
a good time as any in the summer time
the situation's changed vaccines have
allowed us to have these events now
and we can do so safely the risk is not
zero but it's
much better than it was uh even a couple
months ago then there is the team itself
on the cusp of being a post-season
contender featuring a big hitting lineup
of young stars
led by one of the most talented
charismatic players in the game today
vladimir guerrero jr the return should
enhance sponsorship
fan support and even the team's
performance on the field
with this kind of latent pent-up demand
it will hopefully explode in the form of
great passion at the games which can
hopefully lift the team to some wins
the team even acquired a big name
pitcher jose barrios from minnesota
at today's trade deadline making the
team even more competitive this season
eric sorensen global news and that is
global national for this friday i'm nitu
garcia we'll leave you tonight with some
of toronto's landmarks lit up in white
and blue for its baseball team
niagara falls is putting on a bright
show for the blue jays too
let's play ball thanks for watching eric
sorenson will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow
have a good night
[Music]
you